I mean anybody who tells you they know
what the future of journalism is now is
is blowin smoke hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and today we're talking
with Bill Keller who spent most of his
career as a reporter and editor at the
New York Times
serving as the papers executive editor
from 2003 to 2011 in early 2014
he left the Gray Lady to head up the
Marshall project a new nonprofit news
organization that seeks to bring
attention to the nation's broken
criminal justice system bill thanks for
sitting with us you're welcome
talk a little bit about the Marshall
projects mission and what are you hoping
to achieve with us you know the mission
is journalistic not it's not advocacy we
don't have an agenda of specific reforms
we won't we want to see enacted but the
mission is to raise the the issues
profile to stimulate debate create a
sense of urgency about the condition of
the criminal justice system
how does journalism do that you know
obviously there's political activism and
advocacy and you know what what does
journalism bring to that's that felt
need for change it brings information on
subjects like this it's often
information that's hard to get and
honestly information that people aren't
eager to read about you know the
criminal justice system engages a
demographic that is not your newspaper
reading public for the most part you
know which is one reason that editors
have cut back on coverage of these
issues maybe they cover crime but they
don't really cover the criminal justice
system what are the pieces that you've
been most that you think most fully
embody what you're trying to do so far
well it's a range we're doing longer
investigative pieces we're doing longer
term magazine style narratives and then
we're doing a pretty steady flow of
daily pieces where we aim to you know
find angles that are being overlooked or
under-covered or Mis covered for our
debut a month or so ago we did a
partnership with the Washington Post
meaning basically we gave them a piece
that we've been working on for a while
about lawyers who blow the deadline for
death penalty cases meaning that their
clients
the last and most important round of
Appeals and I like that story for a
couple of reasons one of them was it's
big and complicated and I think you know
the it's always a challenge to do
complicated well and that and something
that I've always regarded as a one of
the highest ambitions of journalism and
also it was a story that was mostly
about guilty people it's very easy to
generate sympathy for the wrong
wrongfully convicted
you know the Innocence Project does
heroic work but the criminal justice
system mostly engages people who are
guilty and nonetheless it it fails us
you know what led you to leave your
comfortable perch at the Times I mean
you had to earn your column and
everything to start for a you know a
kind of moderately funded or you know
tentative tenuously funded smaller
functioning news startup you mean you
want to hear about my midlife crisis if
that's what it was you know it wasn't a
midlife crisis although it was a I guess
partly motivated by a desire to have an
next act I mean I was at the Times for
30 years
I had some of the best jobs in the world
first and foremost being a foreign
correspondent in times of real people
it looks South Africa in South Africa in
Russia you know I mean you can't
complain about a perch as a hotbed
columnist at the New York Times you've
got a great audience and all kinds of
freedom but I did find that I sort of
missed just the sitting around with a
bunch of smart people trying to figure
out a problem the problem might be how
are you gonna cover the Arab Spring or
it might be although I'm hearing you
saying there aren't any smart people
left at the New York Times now there are
lots of lower lots of smart people at
the New York Times but we better call on
this role there is pretty much lonely
yeah you don't spend a lot of time
consulting you know in your fascinating
2013 online debate with Glenn Greenwald
about journalism and what makes for good
or bad journalism you expressed a the
view that suspending passion helps make
for more effective better journalism and
there's a variety of interesting pieces
on the site relate it's a criminal
justice reform but the framing and the
headlines are pretty dispassionate we
cover reason covers the same issues from
the same perspective but with headlines
meant to in
kind of outraged internet you know and
provoke provoke empathy and you know be
provoked
I mean basically what what's going on
with your ethos they're like how you
know what's the play that you're making
I mean first of all I should say I know
that you guys have a passionate interest
in criminal justice because Andrew Cohen
who does our daily runs later dotes on
go great on the links to reason my
instincts are to try to keep the
temperature low to have a rational
discussion not a screaming match but we
you know I do like headlines that make
you want to read the story I mean
everybody seems to be consuming more
news from more sources or at least more
information or more media do you think
that people read errs and consumers of
media are more sophisticated now and
there or are they you know it is the
kind of a BuzzFeed or and up where these
style headline you know what clickbait
headline the only way to really catch
people's attention you know I like to
think that people are sophisticated
enough to actually pick and choose
serious in-depth reporting and and I
mean the evidence is an awful lot of
them are drawn to cat videos and you
know buzzy headlines and listicles you
know I'm not above using a listicle if
it will get somebody to read about the
death penalty or the fraud condition of
police community relations in the debate
with Greenwald use he said that
objectivity is a suffocating constraint
on how reporters are permitted to
express themselves and it produces a
self neutering form of journalism that
and he said that becomes as ineffectual
as it is boring you know give your
capsule of response to that is it is he
right or is he is he partly right as he
just off you know off the reservation
well no I mean he's he's partly right I
mean look I read a lot of polemical
writing I enjoy it I like a good
argument you know it gets the blood
flowing and it makes people think that's
great I read Glenn Greenwald but I think
that there's a really important place
for journalism that sees as its
obligation to get the readers trust
right and you do that
by sort of suppressing you know I don't
like to use the word objective because
it conjures up some sort of
philosophical perfect state of truth I
prefer impartial but I think to make a
deliberate discipline out of laying
aside your Compassion's convictions and
prejudices and to try to see your way to
through to the truth
small team I think is an extremely
valuable discipline it doesn't mean that
you fall into false equivalencies I mean
you know the the evidence will often
tell you that one point of view has more
merit than and and your work I mean at
the Marshall project it's not as if this
form of objectivity or this form of kind
of measured analysis doesn't actually
have a point of view because I mean the
stories you tell all kind of come to the
same conclusion right that the criminal
justice system is in desperate need of
reform right there most of the stories
are about dysfunction in the system
although we're making a concerted effort
to find examples of things that work
which we'll look at skeptically but
we'll highlight them when we find them
do you think that in terms of social
change that gets a larger project of
social change I mean you have political
activism and advocacy of policy change
and then within the journalism spaces
that often a function of kind of
overlapping like people moving in the
same direction so you might have
activist bloggers as doing one thing in
polemical journalist and then people who
are doing more along the lines of what
you're doing and that that is is it kind
of the gestalt of that that actually
changes things yeah I think that's right
I think journalism you know if the
actual change is at least the final
stages of it is in the hands of people
who are elected who people who make
policy and advocates who have a draft
legislation for them but what
journalists can do is create a context
where the advocates get listened to and
the policymakers get persuaded and
that's true both of the you know
straight-ahead journalism that we try to
practice and the more polemical
journalism you're working now at a 501c3
a non
research and educational institution do
you think that's the future of
journalism or a big future of journal a
big part of the future for journalism as
a kind of funding mechanism is
nonprofits yo I think it's a future I
don't know how big I don't think I mean
anybody who tells you they know what the
future of journalism is now is is blowin
smoke I like to refer to us as nonprofit
on purpose
distinct from the rest of the media
which is just nonprofit although I mean
even at the times it's not so is it that
it's not profitable or it's that it's
not as now I'm being yeah I'm that way
and obviously but talk a little bit
about that because that seems I mean to
go from say a 30% return on investment
to a 10 percent return on investment it
seems to be cataclysmic whereas most
industries in America or you know lucky
to make any money so how does that how
does that like create such a earthquake
in journalism well first of all people
had sort of built their lives around the
30% return on investment and second of
all an awful lot of journalistic
ventures these days are not anywhere
close to 10% return on investment or any
return on investment and you know and
for most people in this business it's
personal you've seen friends laid off
you've seen newspapers scrap their print
editions or go to twice a week you've
seen the kind of stories that really
should be covered you know state
capitals state legislatures you know
going uncovered which are you know
places that somebody really ought to be
paying close attention to all right well
we'll leave it there for Reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie and we've been talking to
Bill Keller who's heading up the
Marshall project which is a great
nonprofit investigative journalism
outfit dedicated to criminal justice
reform thanks Bob you're welcome